[Music]
hello again friends Drex here from Drex
Factor po sharing with you the love of
Po spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and I'm back in the
dance studio to teach you more basic po
dance steps specifically we're going to
work through something called a pot
Beret or grape vine but before we dive
into that I want to give a quick shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
ter light toys spinballs and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- buus friend of the channel Becca
beckon thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission po Beret make for a great way to
get across a stage not the least of
which because they engage our feet in
such a way that we always keep the same
side of our body facing the audience I'm
going to show you how to do pot Beret
and which poy tricks are the best
compliment to these so let's check it
out all right so by now bunch of you are
probably wondering what exactly is a
poet well a PO Beret really is just a
series of double time steps that allow
you to switch which of your feet is in
front it's sometimes used as a
preparation to get into something else
in French it means step of the boret
which B itself is an older form of
French folk dance that pieces of it uh
essentially got brought into the ballet
world now the version of this that I
want to focus on is something that's
also called a grape vine in jazz dance
and it looks look something like this we
want to head far over to stage left here
and I'm going to start this off with my
feet next to each other shoulder width
I'm going to step in front of my right
foot with my left foot so I'm all
crossed up here but my the front of my
body is still facing downstage towards
my audience from here I step out with my
right foot and I'm going to step behind
with my left foot so again my upper body
still facing down stage as I'm all
twisted up here and finally I'm going to
open back up with my right foot having
traveled over to Stage right I can go
back to stage left by First Crossing my
right foot in front of my left foot
opening up crossing my right foot behind
my left foot and then opening up once
again so the pattern you want to see
here is that you're Crossing in front
open Crossing behind open again Crossing
in front open Crossing behind open
technically speaking you could cross
behind Open Cross in front open if you
really wanted to it doesn't really
matter the order that that happens in
just so long as you're alternating in
front behind as you're going back and
forth across the stage so then what
pyric go well with this I tend to find
that py Trix that work well with Potter
Beret have two specific qualities in
common number one they're in Split Time
same direction the reason for this being
that as we travel across the stage I
think that split time same direction is
a great compliment because it kind of
just looks like a wheel rolling to that
side of the stage number two and this
one is really important these have to be
poy moves that involve the upper body
turning back and forth to go with the
orientation of our body as we're taking
these steps I can think of three pyric
off the top of my head that are a great
fit those are tuck turns crossers and
meltdowns okay so I know that I said
that split Time same direction works
best for this but trust me tuck turns do
work in this regard here's how we start
over here on stage left and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go ahead and
drop my PO behind my shoulders like so
and as I'm going to try and pull them
back out that automatically takes my
upper body over to Stage right which
means it's a great opportunity for me to
step towards stage right with my left
foot crossing my feet up as the poy come
out from behind my back I can take my
step out with my right foot
and as my poy are going back behind my
hips that's an excellent opportunity to
bring my left foot back behind my right
specifically because it automatically
turns my upper body back over to stage
left when that happens I can bring my
POI back out as I open up my legs and
then do another loop behind my shoulders
to stop over on stage right if I want to
go back to stage left once again I do a
loop behind my shoulders and as I'm
taking my hands and po back back out
that automatically takes me towards
stage left and means that I can do a
step with my right foot in front of my
left as I open up I can then do my beat
behind my uh my waist and step back with
my right for coming out doing a loop
behind my shoulders and coming back out
to Stage Left here's what that looks
like Al together I go over I go under
and back I go over I go under and back
just
like that going back and forth all right
so now let's do the same thing with
crossers because crossers go a little
bit faster than our tuck turns do that
also means we need to be faster with our
footwork but likewise we find cases
where the body is turned over toward
stage right and cases where it's turned
over to Stage Left let's see what this
looks like shall we so as I'm doing my
crossers when I'm bringing both of them
over to the forward side that's my
opportunity to step out with my left
foot as I open I want to switch back on
my left foot as I switch over to the
reverse side here and then when I open
back up I'm going to want to do a
pendulum or something here to switch the
direction of the PO back the other way
as I go back towards stage left I'm
going to turn towards forwards with my
right foot forward open and then
immediately get my right foot behind me
as I'm turning towards the POI spinning
what looks like reverse for me and then
open back up and switch the direction of
the POI it's going to look like this as
I go around from side to
side like
so
and like so all right so my final
example and probably my favorite is the
Meltdown part of what I love so much
about the Meltdown is not only does it
require us to turn our upper body from
side to side but the pattern of it also
works fantastically with a grapevine /pt
Beret here's how when we start our step
over to Stage right with the left foot I
can bring my right hand around behind my
back and basically team it up with that
left foot I can then open up and when I
step behind with my left foot it's now
my left hand that is spinning behind my
back and when I open up I can do a
little stall and switch the direction of
the PO here as I go back the other way
as my right foot steps in front I can
bring my left hand behind me and as I
open up I can then bring my right foot
behind me with my right hand spinning
behind my back and do a stall and open
up so going back and forth looks like
this I go to Stage right stall I go to
Stage Left stall I go to Stage right
stall I go to Stage Left stall beautiful
right so now let me show you all three
examples in
[Music]
action
cool so I hope that helped to inspire
those of you out there that are working
on your own po Dan and gave you some
great ideas if you wouldn't mind please
shoot some vide some of the things that
you explore as a result both of these
ideas and posted online and please make
sure to tag me so I can see your great
work in the meantime please make sure to
leave a like comment below on some
tricks that you would love to see work
with these Potter Beret or even other
dance tricks that you'd like to see me
do videos on and make sure to share and
subscribe as well to help other people
find this video and to help my channel
[Music]
grow
this video would not be possible without
my amazing patreon supporters in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now if you dug this video
and you'd like to see more like it the
best way to make that happen is to sign
up to support my work over on patreon
there's a lot of things I have to do in
order to bring money in the door and
quite frankly some of them take me away
from being able to make videos so if you
want to see more highquality videos like
this one please head on over to
patreon.com factor poo and sign up every
little dollar helps me get closer to
being able to pay rent without having to
do the other stuff so go check that out
please and thank you and if you dug this
video on pot of beret and pyrx you might
also dig the video that I recently did
on gads and pyrx I will go ahead and
leave a link to that down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on YouTube thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow and dance yourself this weekend
and I'll see you with a new video real
soon take care now peace